my guest tonight is a very talented
actress who appeared in such classic
movies as swingers
the hangover and of course boogie nights
her latest film
wander is out now in theaters video on
demand
and digital please welcome our very good
friend heather graham heather you look
amazing
you look fantastic i dressed up for you
all right thank you
no seriously you look absolutely
gorgeous uh and i've been talking to
everybody in
during covid and i have to say
you're killing it right now you do not
look like you're suffering through
a quarantine or a pandemic you look
amazing
thank you i'm definitely trying not to
gain weight i did gain a little weight
but then i think i lost it i mean i
think my goal is just don't gain weight
basically
really are you did you get obsessive
about that or you're just oh
no but my boyfriend started cooking and
everything he wants to cook is really
fattening you know chicken tikka masala
and pizza
and so um yeah really now wait a minute
i've always been jealous of men
that could whip something up in the
kitchen i could never ever do that
it is cute it is cute but yeah i mean i
think men find it really sexy when women
cook too right
uh well we're just monsters i don't know
that we find it i mean my wife cooks but
i don't know that i find it
uh sexy as much as it's just i need to
eat
a lot all the time so it's just uh yeah
i wish i could think well you need a lot
of energy
right i'm so tall i'm like a nuclear
reactor i've got to burn so much fuel
uh you know i want to ask you something
because
you famously in uh boogie nights
which is one of my all-time favorite
movies as roller girl you're on roller
skates the whole time and then you
just brought it back on tick-tock yeah
yeah well there's all these really cool
girls you know
roller skating during the during the
pandemic i was getting really inspired
by them because they look really hot
it looks fun and i just wanted to get
back out there but it's very hard
you know when i first learned i needed a
coach because it's hard
and it's very easy to just fall over and
kill yourself
and also i would think you had to act on
roller skates
you had to you had to perform and also
you were on wheels the entire time which
sounds to me
next to impossible i mean you pulled it
off beautifully but i can't believe you
didn't know how to roller skate when you
got that roll
no i mean it was so fun and then you see
these girls now they roller skate
backwards and they just make it look so
easy so i tried to do that and it was
very hard you know and i live in new
york and it's
it's not that easy to find just like a
quiet street where there's
no cars right so what you're saying is
during quarantine basically how you're
getting around in manhattan is on roller
skates you're just everywhere only on
roller skates
no but every time you hit a bomb i
actually bike everywhere that's what i
do i just bike everywhere but roller
skates is like if you go over like a
rock or there's like an uneven piece
you're just like
you know it's so easy to just wipe out
basically um
let's talk about this boyfriend uh i
have some gel i have some jealousies
uh i want to know who this guy is you
and i have known each other for a long
time
i always thought i was the right one for
you but you went another way
you're married so it would be hard to
make that work
i don't know i'm very flexible in my
thinking uh
i have a very european attitude towards
marriage now
okay um my wife can't stand me so you
know we'll talk about that later that's
a separate call
a private call who is this guy i hear
he's from amsterdam why is your
boyfriend from amsterdam
okay he's see i've always kind of
thought guys from other countries were
kind of cute right because they have an
accent or like oh they
speak italian or they speak spanish you
know but dutch is like not a very sexy
language
like when a guy speaks dutch it's like
my god maybe he has something wrong with
his throat it is a
it's an ugly language i'll just say that
hey here he is he's cute you know he
starts talking in dutch and i'm like oh
i'm going to get all turned on because
he's speaking in another language but
then it's just like
so you like guys that are from uh
european countries
i mean i do like a guy with an accent
but i mean you know i'm open-minded i
could also like an american guy but um
but yeah dutch is not the sexiest
language
did you know that i was born in norway
wow
let's hear you speak in another language
what
yeah i lived in norway until about four
years ago
wow yeah i came to america four years
ago and more sexy every minute i mean do
you remember the movie fish called wanda
she was really turned on by accents too
yeah no i just thought you should know
born and raised
in norway don't ask me too much about
norway
various cities and things i i don't know
but i had a lot of herring growing up
and there was a fjord nearby i remember
that very well
being a viking you know yeah well i've
got that kind of you know
viking thing about me yeah um
you uh how are you getting through this
pandemic because you seem
like a very serene calm person i've
always thought that about you
and i've thought that you would be
probably
very i don't know uh
even keeled during this crisis well i
can get pretty
you know nervous sometimes so but i do a
lot of yoga and i've been doing this
thing called yoga nidra because i have
trouble falling asleep um my boyfriend
he falls asleep really fast i get really
mad and really jealous and so can i say
one thing why do you keep bringing up
the boyfriend
everything goes back to the boyfriend we
get it
okay well conan it's just about you and
me right now okay so i have trouble
falling asleep so i do yoga nidra maybe
you might enjoy it
uh this woman talks to you in this
really soothing voice her name is
jennifer piercy i'm obsessed with her
and she just goes like your left ear
your right ear
your left nostril your right nostril
sense of vacation mouth and then i'm
like
isn't that yeah that made me feel really
relaxed she's like feel a sense of
vacation mouth you know and i'm like oh
because i clenched my jaw and i'm like
oh it really helps you relax your mouth
so
vicky so what she does is you go you you
you
focus on whatever area of your face or
your body and then you get to your mouth
and you say vacation mouth
yeah is it working for you this is my
vacation
mouth it looks the same
i know it looks good now
i'm just looking at wherever i go you
know that old saying wherever you go
there you are
yeah well she said funny things like
free your eyes
i'm like i don't know what that means
but i don't want my eyes to be freed
i want them in the sockets where they
belong i don't want them gangling around
her voice just makes you go like like
you know oh her voice is amazing
and then um she gets the whole body
relaxed
yeah oh and she says she says free
yourself into the healing darkness
let your worries go into the healing
darkness can i say something heather
that's what they say to people
when they uh when they're dying and they
want them to let go
i just want you to remember that you
know they gather around the bed and go
you can go now
go go go leave uh what's your
boyfriend's name what's his first name
his name is dennis
wait you just went on you went on and on
and on about
how exotic and he's dutch i thought his
name was going to be like struden
dennis his name's
larry what are you talking about
her dog is named dennis so every time
she's talking to her dog i think about
my boyfriend
waits dennis that's ridiculous
is it too boring for you well no he's
supposed to have this exotic name
like yes
every time you say his name you should
have to get out some windex and a wipe
um let's talk about uh let's talk about
this movie wander
that you did um you worked with uh aaron
eckert
in this uh in this in this movie and i'm
told that he went
method he was doing some married method
like honestly sometimes when we were
talking i couldn't tell
if i was really talking to him or he was
in character um like you know he had to
have like dirt on him and some scenes
and usually like a makeup artist will
put it on you but he would just grab
dirt off the ground and just like smear
it all over himself and
be like really angry and one day i was
driving to work and i just you know i
was like oh there's this homeless man
sitting outside the set like on this
curb
and it was it was aaron maybe he's had
financial setbacks
have you ever thought about that
um let's show a clip from uh wander and
i believe
uh he is very paranoid you're meeting in
this senior meeting
with him in a diner yeah and um
he of course very paranoid and uh
you think that this is all about him
being off his meds not taking care of
himself
yes and we'll find out maybe that's the
case
but maybe it isn't maybe not yes let's
take a look at this clip
you haven't been going to your
appointments that's because sometimes i
can't tell who's the doc and who's not
that's a whack job you want to get
better you got to go to your
appointments
i'm just looking out for you i just
grown up show
how about you and nick
mr tall dark and fbi why can't you just
be happy for me
i'm looking out for you you're looking
out for me you don't think it's at all
coincidental
that he just happened to be transferred
into town and you go out with you yeah
you're going too far with this
conspiracy thing and you know what i
blame jimmy yeah well at least he
believes me well you met him in 51.50
he's a crazy person i mean he gets in
your head he provokes oh hey
gee shell the whole back my only friend
what about me can we get a check
and we're back love that
that was fast at home they just saw a
clip
but we don't show the clip on zoom here
now yeah
really phony thing where i say let's
take a look and then you and i are just
staring at each other and i say
and we're back i know um
you know i apologize for that it's very
but i think unprofessional fun i'm so
happy to talk to somebody who's not in
my close family group right now i mean
it's it's it's fun
yeah probably getting tired of the
boyfriend
that's what's happening a lot of
relationships are under strain right now
because of quarantine
you know what i've never dated anyone
norwegian i think i need to
think about that okay can i just say one
thing i hope it lasts forever with this
guy i really do
but if you date another norwegian for
any reason
uh or you know uh any guy who's
they should have a real exotic name okay
dennis
okay okay you know what name would be
acceptable to you for example
written down breathing down
that should be his name just call him
that
you know tonight when he's in the
kitchen making this fantastic meal that
i would never know how to cook
say great too much salt
okay that would be an awesome name it
would
um i also want to mention the stand is
coming out
very soon and that was shot before all
of this craziness
yeah i mean it's about a pandemic yeah
and it's about a virus
you know that kills all these people and
we shot it in october a year ago
about you know a little more than a year
ago so in a way by making that movie
maybe you cause you blame
me for the pandemic is that what you're
saying i do
okay you you are the highlight of my day
which uh
seriously i love talking to you i always
have and
um i'm very happy that you're happy and
that all's well
thank you so much for having me on my on
your show i think you're lovely human
and you you made my day great too
wander it's available now
i went into a reverie for a minute
[Laughter]
wander is available now in theaters
video on demand and digital and the
stand premieres december 17th
on cbs all access um
so nice talking to you happy holidays
stay well
and um once again i'll say it
uh you look absolutely fantastic and
you're delight so i bow to you
i bow to you and your christmasy
decorations look very festive
isn't that great yeah cost us 40 dollars